in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I helped some texture compression
gurus solve their bucket creation
problems will we zip up their
performance stay tuned to find out
encode alamode came to us with a small
problem their cloud-based texture
compression service was handling 23,000
encodings a day and some of their
clients were starting to notice that the
time it took to export their data was
starting to get significantly longer
their system works something like this
for each build their script would create
a new bucket in cloud storage upload all
the textures from the client and then
kick off work to a load balancer we're a
bunch of compute engine instances would
start converting textures their setup
required that for each batch of textures
to be uploaded a unique bucket was
created so they can more easily track
the progress of encoding state although
their setup was pretty sound they
couldn't ignore their customers notes
about performance so it was time to dig
in and figure out the problem our first
step was to check the load balancing and
scaling operation if everything so is
setup right new instances should be spun
up properly so to check that out we
looked at the CPU utilization for the
instance group the values were low about
in the 12% range and there was only
about three to four instances running so
the problem was not that the instances
were getting overloaded now a CPU rates
that low the next thing we had to check
to make sure was that this machines
weren't getting stalled crashing or
hitting a weird error condition but
according to the logs they were
receiving data right on time and in fact
most of the instances in the group were
sitting around just waiting for work
with the instance group removed as a
potential source of the problem we set
our gaze to the GCS bucket and how the
team was using it and lo and behold ran
right into the issue it turns out that
there is a per project rate limit to
bucket creation and deletion of
approximately one operation every two
seconds according to the documentation
for them this meant that if 30 artists
across multiple companies all tried to
export at the same time then random
folks would start getting exception 429
to be thrown signaling that the rate was
exceeded for bucket creation where this
turned into a performance problem was
that the Python API their tool was using
had to implement an exponential back-off
and reach rot which is a nice and common
practice but since the queue was getting
backed up folks were ending up waiting a
longer
I'm for a simple export turns out they
didn't need that much dynamic bucket
creation instead they created one bucket
for each artists ads they registered
with the system this removed the entire
bucket creation bottleneck making things
a lot faster and made it easier to
handle tracking down what assets were
causing problems in the case of an error
to learn more about the perf details of
these buckets check out the article
linked in the description below
and don't forget to check out the rest
of our cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts